bei mir ist jetzt die verdi
verhandlungsführerin christine behle und
damit eben schon mal einen guten morgen
guten morgen also streik muss wehtun
aber einen streik mitten in der
urlaubssaison der tut doch den falschen
b also warum ausgerechnet jetzt ja das
problem ist dass da im luftverkehr ja
nicht streiken können ohne dass
passagiere davon ein schaden haben das
ist leider in der natur der sache so und
wir machen uns streiks natürlich auch
nicht leicht wir haben jetzt
tarifverhandlungen deswegen kann man
auch streiks nicht nach tarif wandlung
machen sondern sie liegen immer in
tariff verhandlungsseiten kann nicht
verschoben werden und wir machen uns
natürlich gedanken darüber wann kann man
so was machen und zu welchem zeitpunkt
und versuchen somit wie möglich zu
machen ja gut aber in der urlaubszeit
und in der ferienzeit ist das natürlich
alles andere als mit jetzt haben sie
gerade schon die verhandlungsrunde
angesprochen es gab bereits 2 die dritte
ist aber doch schon terminiert für
anfang august dritter vierter august
also warum dann doch dieses eben nicht
milde soll man doch eher grobe vorgehen
na ja wir hatten extra eine
expertenrunde eingefügt jetzt am 13.7
die waren ursprünglich nicht geplant
weil wir auch die luft haben sagen
großes interesse daran hatten nicht
diese verhandlung eskalieren zu lassen
sondern zu versuchen vorher einen
abschluss zu machen das ist nicht
gelungen es gab zwar ein angebot das es
gut dass es eins gibt es reicht aber
überhaupt nicht aus ist vielleicht nicht
inflation aus und die beschäftigten sie
haben die situation ja gestellt bekommen
die beschäftigten die sind wirklich eine
extrem angespannten belastenden
situationen und die brauchen jetzt
entlastung über das angebot sprechen wir
natürlich gleich noch noch mal eine
frage zu dem streik umfang volumen jetzt
nicht zeitpunkt 26 er im halbstunden das
ist doch kein warnstreik mehr
warnstreiks gehen eigentlich aber ein
paar stunden wir haben ja im
lufthansa-konzern im luftverkehr
schichtdienste das heißt man kann ich
einfach sagen man nimmt eine schicht
raus dann ist der gesamte tag pausiert
sondern wir versuchen alle beschäftigten
einzubeziehen dass auch die
erwartungshaltung an uns und insofern
ist dieser zeitpunkt so terminiert dass
er vom frühesten schichtbeginn bis zum
späten schicht ende ist so dass alle
beschäftigten einbezogen werden man
könnte natürlich sagen warum verhandeln
sie nicht erst mal weiter warum wird
gestreikt aber offensichtlich gefällt
ihnen das angebot der lufthansa mit was
kritisieren sie denn daran naja die
lufthansa also ich fand mal mit den
guten sachen weil die sind natürlich
auch dabei diese lufthansa hat eine
starke soziale komponente angeboten das
ist gut weil wir haben im lufthansa
konzern tatsächlich noch menschen die
haben stunden vergütung von zehn euro 4
sonst ein mindestlohn der aber im
oktober angenommen wird angehoben wird
ja das ist so und deswegen ist diese
starke soziale komponente auch eine gute
das problem ist das reicht hinten und
vorne nicht aus wir haben ja drei
komponenten bekommen zwei mal ne
festbetrag und dann gibt es eine dritte
komponente ab mitte nächsten jahres soll
die vergütung noch mal um zwei prozent
angehoben werden allerdings dann nicht
fest sondern abhängig vom ergebnis also
nur dann wenn die lufthansa ein
positives ergebnis sagt das ist also
blankoscheck den die beschäftigten
ausstellen soll dieses zweite große der
zweite große kritikpunkt ist dann
natürlich dass die laufzeit sehr lang
ist 18 monate in diesen zeiten mit
dieser inflationsrate ist das überhaupt
nicht nachvollziehbar und es ist
insgesamt einfach zu niedrig wie sie
sagen ja oder ihre forderung neuneinhalb
prozent mehr lohn auch aufgrund der
inflation und zwölf monate laufzeit ja
wo sind sie denn kompromissbereit das
kann man jetzt hier nicht in denen es
mir schon nicht sein wir können ja auch
gerne tarif handlung führen aber nicht
fühlen aber natürlich sind wir
kompromissbereit das ist glaube ich auch
klar keine gewerkschaft geht hin und
sagt das ist unsere forderung die muss
am ende rauskommen aber klar ist dass
die beschäftigten hier wirklich eine
starke erhöhung brauchen weil sie sind
ja nicht nur von dieser inflation jetzt
bestraft sondern die haben die situation
dass durch die pandemie natürlich die
beschäftigen luft daran hansa konzern
ganz besonders betroffen sind die letzte
erhöhung war vor drei jahren und sie
haben erheblich geld abgegeben in den
letzten jahren auch der lufthansa hat ja
bereits eingestanden dass dieser
sparkurs als leser aber eine letzte
kurze frage mit der bitte um eine kurze
antwort können sie ausschließen dass vor
dem dritten oder vierten august noch mal
gestreikt wird das kann ich ausschließen
dann sage ich an dieser stelle
herzlichen dank dass sie sich heute am
streiktag die zeit genommen haben das
war die verdi verhandlungsführerin
christine behle danke in st